down of rocks the name Chaos is a game a
corresponding right on time to cover all
the crime so when you think All Is Lost
[Applause]
[Music]
there are
there's lots of crimes to unpack so
we're bringing that chaos Queen back you
may recall last month we welcome to the
show Rihanna Brock a Kentucky woman
whose incredible array of mug shots from
her multiple arrests went viral but now
that she's turned her life around I
thought who better to discuss weird
crimes and mug shots than with the queen
of chaos herself please welcome back our
new Gutfeld crime correspondent Brianna
Brock how are you
[Applause]
before we get to the storage Rihanna has
anything changed for you since you came
on our show last month
um A lot's changed actually I've had so
many great interviews and just
opportunities in general I just finished
up getting back from New York I did a
interview with Inside Edition I have a
couple reality shows I'm interested in
doing so there's like a lot in the works
all right well if you want me to read
over any of the contracts
I charge because they will try to
destroy you all right here are a few
crime stories and I want to get your
take on the first one two Florida women
oh that's scary already
there they are look at that they were
recently arrested after a fight over
stolen vape pens and the woman on the
left with her head bandaged had a piece
of her ear bitten off in the scuffle
Rihanna what do you make of these mug
shots you're the queen of mug shots she
seems pretty happy about losing an ear
what do you think
honestly when I've seen these I was glad
that both of them still had a smirk on
their face like they got in a little
tussle but you know they didn't let it
like dim their smile and you know I love
that
when I first looked at these mug shots
though I thought the girl on the right
with the black eye definitely had her
ear bitten off because I thought the
girl with the white bandages on I
thought that was a headband yeah so but
then once I looked closer I was like no
the girl with the bandages definitely
got the ear bit off yeah it's an
interesting uh discussion uh we will say
We'll table that for later but do you
have any advice for them if they get
into another fight in the future
I will say one thing about my generation
is we do not play about our vape pens so
I would say just my advice is you know
keep your Vape in your pocket and you
won't like have to accuse anybody of
stealing it and some ear muffs yeah get
earmarks ear muffs ear muffs and a vape
pen holder okay next crime this comes
with video a bank robber in Ohio was
caught by cops by falling through a
ceiling directly into a trash can let's
watch watch this
oh
[Applause]
get out get out okay just put your hand
s behind your back so as someone Rihanna
who was also caught during her
Misadventures unlike this guy were there
any times when you got away
there's been a couple times I would say
two times that I ran from the police and
I actually escaped and got away so
um the luck was in my favor those nights
I feel like you know for him if he
didn't have bad luck he probably
wouldn't have any at all
Tyrus here America reports
um you were so funny making that joke
about how you escaped from the police
because that would mean those charges
would still be pending so she's so funny
she's so funny
did they ever track you down later
I actually they told me they was like
listen if you don't come back and turn
yourself in we're charging you for like
seven felonies because I did give like a
random fake name so I ended up turning
myself back in just to avoid those extra
charges
what's the name
is your fake name
I think it was like Maddie Bratton which
is so funny because my best friend's
name is Maddie Stratton so that was just
all right we got one more crime a
Minnesota man with a heart-shaped tattoo
under his eye was arrested after
bursting into a restaurant and throwing
Skittles at employees and patrons ran
out Skittles are an odd choice to throw
at people uh do you think he was on
something when he did this
you know like I said Xanax man it it'll
tear anybody up
and you know I think after this they're
probably gonna make everyone get like a
background check if you want to like buy
Skittles because I've never heard of
like assault by Skittles before that's a
new one there's so many other heavier
candies that would hurt more than
Skittles that's not true Greg it's hard
to catch a rainbow
[Laughter]
Skittles Taste the rainbow come on guys
are your parents are they around are
they uh are they digging your new life
as a crime correspondent
my dad is actually in prison but he
watches you're all shown all the time
yeah and he actually told me to tell Cat
that he loves her laugh and it helps him
fall asleep which is really weird but
let's check this out that checks out
wait I'm surprised Pat you have fans in
prison no
I already knew that I did it's the
letters well thank you Rihanna Brock
good job everyone the queen of Chaos
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else